max gallo
j'ai moi même
bonsoir alors après de nombreux romans
des essais des bio après quatre volumes
sur napoléon quatre volumes sur de
gaulle vous attaquer une nouvelle suite
romanesque en cinq volumes consacrés aux
romains dont le premier tome s'intitule
spartacus la révolte des esclaves
c'est chez fayard alors spartacus on le
connaît évidemment à travers le film de
stanley kubrick avec des musiques avec
kirk douglas la comédie musicale de
lévis show acquis mais là c'est une
somme a vraiment la d 4 165 pages si si
je me lance sur spartacus parce qu'on
vit dans une société qui par certains
côtés ressemble beaucoup à l'enppi rome
les drames que vous enfin le drame la
tragédie le meurtre la mort la violence
les gens dans les trains etc et en même
temps la sophistication
c'est à dire qu'ici nous sommes sur un
plateau qui après tout pourrait être une
pièce dans un dans un palais impérial et
moi ce qui m'a fasciné dans l'empiré
romain dans les romains plus exactement
et dans le cadre spartacus c'est que on
a une société vit dans des sociétés où
il ya côte à côte en même temps le
sublime et l'horreur la barbarie et puis
en même temps et en même temps la
civilisation les romains c'est le droit
c'est celle architecture c'est
l'intelligence c'est la philosophie
c'est tout ce qu'on veut puis en même
temps c'est spartacus un gladiateur
c'est des millions d'esclaves des gens
qu'on en voit dans les cirques et moi je
crois que le 21e siècle que nous vivons
est menacée par la même chose
c'est-à-dire une société très
sophistiqué le portable
l'intelligence la beauté galileo tout ce
qu'on veut la télé
les paillettes tout ça c'est très bien
et en même temps une barbarie total et
si je me suis lancé dans la série des
romains c'est pour essayer de de
comprendre à travers une société la
nôtre l'esclavagé on en parle beaucoup
par exemple aujourd'hui c'est un débat
violent
napoléon a rétabli l'esclavagé c'est un
criminel
l'esclavagé est un crime contre
l'humanité évidemment c'est un crime
contre l'humanité et en même temps vous
avez pendant des millénaires et sous
l'empiré romain vous avez d'aider des
personnages des types aussi aussi
extraordinaire que sénèque où l'empereur
marc aurèle des gens qui sont des
méditatif des philosophes ça les dérange
pas du tout qui est à côté de vienne des
millions d'esclaves et la révolte de
spartacus c'est précisément un moment où
ces esclaves ont soixante dix avant
jésus-christ et bien ces esclaves ils
disent on veut être libre mais ce sont
quand même des brutes se sont quand même
des sauvages oui la civilisation
curieusement la civilisation
malgré cette cette totale inhumanité ce
crime contre l'humanité qu'est
l'esclavagé la civilisation c'est quand
même rome c'est à dire ceux qui ont des
millions d'esclaves
donc voilà alors la main la morale du
truc en tous les cas c'est ce dont on se
souvient ne meurt pas ouais parce que de
la faille il faut absolument que je dise
en tout cas si vous retenez ça ça suffit
va pas pour pas pour le livre mais pour
moi va pour pour comprendre le type
thiam enfin le consul qui a écrasé
spartacus s'appelait crassus traiter
l'homme le plus riche de rome par
ailleurs et pour que qui était dans le
premier triumvirat avec pour tous
exactement pour que jamais signé
d'autres révoltes il a décidé de réserve
après avoir battu les derniers esclaves
il a décidé d'en garder 6000 qui n'a pas
fait tuer sur le champ de bataille comme
ça se faisait régulièrement et il a fait
dresser sur les 150 200 km qui séparent
capoue là où avait commencé la révolte
de rome le long de cette voie romaine
s'appelle lab
bois à pialat diable il a fait dresser
6000 croit et il a fait crucifier six
mille esclaves
ça c'est en 70 avant jésus-christ vous
comprenez en ce châtiment terrible avait
pour fonction de laissé dans la mémoire
le fait que quand on se révolte contre
rome et bien non seulement on perd mais
on est crucifié les on et supplicié et
vous on comprend bien que quand le
christ en 70 soit un siècle plus tard et
crucifié la signification suisse la
pompe pour les gens de l'époque ce type
ce dieu sauf à ce type là qui prêche au
fond il subit le sort du plus humble de
l'esclave et c'est ça le côté
révolutionnaire de l'apparition du
christianisme et c'est pour ça que c'est
lié à la révolte de spartacus d'une
certaine manière
max gallo les romains la révolte des
esclaves
voilà alors mat
d'autres historiens on vient de le voir
et avec un certain nombre de vos
confrères vous avez récemment signé deux
pétitions demandant que l'état ne se
mêle pas de l'histoire et vous avez
demandé l'abolition des lois gayssot
taubira et acoyer alors il ya beaucoup
de monde avec vous il ya jean pierre
azéma isabelle madame terre l'un d'eux
coup marc ferro jacques julliard rené
rémond pierre vidal naquet rony brauman
jean daniel marcel gauchet alors vous un
souci de clarté
on va rappeler ce que sont ces lois que
vous considérez comme liberticide
alors la loi gayssot d'abord c'est une
loi qui sanctionne la négation des
crimes contre l'humanité qui était fait
l époque surtout pour protéger la
mémoire de la shoah face au
négationnisme tout à fait 1991 voit la
loi pleven 72 reprises par 191 avoriaz
la loi taubira donc reconnaissance de la
traite et de l'esclavagé comme un crime
contre l'humanité et la troisième c'est
la loi acoyer donc reconnaissance du
rôle positif de la présence française
outre-mer bref de la colonisation
donc vous et vos co signataire voulaient
abroger ces trois lois
pourquoi écouter parce que dans une
démocratie il ya des lois qui condamnent
le crime
l'incitation au racisme et qui sont tout
à fait suffisantes
quand on les applique quand on veut les
appliquer pour condamner poursuivre les
gens qui en effet sont des racistes des
antisémistes qui a sitôt crimes ou qui
font l'apologie de l' esclavage par
exemple dès lors s'il ce système existe
si ces lois existent quand on fait des
lois qui définissent des morceaux
d'histoire
ces lois là elle me en fait elles
muselle le débat ya plus de débat car
toutes ces lois que vous venez de
mentionner sont des lois plein de bons
sentiments
disons le avec lesquels sur le fond je
suis d'accord
bien évidemment les arméniens ont été
les victimes d'un génocide bien
évidemment il y à la souffrance des
harkis la souffrance des pieds-noirs et
et qui ont le sentiment d'avoir beaucoup
peu vrai pour la france là où il était
et on peut comprendre que l'on veuille
les satisfaire et surtout participer à
leur peine d'une certaine manière en dix
ans la nation ne vous oublie pas bien
évidemment l'une l'esclavagé est un
crime contre l'humanité et on doit en
effet penser on peut dire cette blessure
séculaire des gens qui se disent nous
avons nous nos ancêtres ont été traités
comme des esclaves tout ça c'est vrai il
n'empêche que quand vous mettez dans une
loi que les professeurs doivent
enseigner de telle et telle manière vous
rendez compte que là vous commencez à
entrer dans des lois qui existait par
exemple je feuilleter un livre sur
l'histoire de l'allemagne de l'est
l'allemagne communiste
il ya des termes pour dire les
professeurs d'histoire doivent faire
ceci et cela
donc on est déjà dans une dans une façon
de limiter le débat de diriger et de
diriger l'enseignement et ça c'est très
grave
et deuxièmement surtout prenons la loi
gayssot c'est la plus légitime je dirais
la shoah et bien entendu aucun des
signataires ne peut être soupçonnée
d'avoir la moindre sympathie pour le
négationnisme avons tous écrit dans nos
livres dix fois cent fois des choses
là-dessus l'envoyer creed est libre
plusieurs ligues même sur ce sujet il
n'empêche que est ce que la loi gayssot
a fait taire 4991 a fait disparaître
l'antisémitisme en france
au contraire on voit on voit peut-être
empêcher la propagation des idées
négationnistes quand même pas du tout la
preuve c'est qu'on voit des gens qui
manie qui détruisent quelle est la
signification de sa qui détruisent les
tombes juives en mettant des croix
gammées on veut au contraire comme on
l'a quand même deux trois exemples de
négationniste qui exerçait alors leur
longue
finalement dans l'enseignement mais mais
romero oui quand par exemple un d'un de
ces négationnistes fait je ne m'aime pas
le citer dit des propos dans une
conférence de presse qui sont tout à
fait condamnable et qu'on le fait qu'on
fait en procès contre lui qu est-ce qu
aux yeux de quelques-uns qu'est ce qu'on
va qu'est ce qu'il va faire il va
apparaître comme une victime
il ya alors que le travail des
historiens a parfaitement montré dans
tous les domaines que les propos qu'il
tient sont tout à fait aberrant bien
relève donc donc dans ce que vous dites
max gallo pour résumer la situation vous
dit
finalement il ya des lois en france sur
les errements de loi pour condamner le
racisme d'antisémitisme etc
laissons les historiens faire leur
travail et que le débat soit ouvert le
débat est ouvert
la vérité finalement est révolutionnaire
la vérité elle s'impose à la fin du
compte
alors alors le président chirac a nommé
jean louis debré à la tête d'une mission
et sarkozy nicolas sarkozy a nommé arno
klarsfeld pour réfléchir sur le sujet